good day my name is Jim gates
I am the president-elect the American
Physical Society and yesterday something
quite remarkable happened I received an
invitation from a friend like this
Illuminati to give this special
presentation to estrange 2020 meeting
it's my very great pleasure to do this
although I must admit my surprise is
sort of overwhelming the worldwide
response of moral revulsion triggered by
the broad decimation of a video showing
the extrajudicial execution of mr.
George Floyd which was the Kucinich
crescendo too far too many such
occurrences has compelled even the
organizers of string 2020 to engage me
in this conversation for their global
cyberspace attendees less I feel
compelled to respond let me start by
reviewing a recent report the United
States the American Institute of Physics
has completed a report called the time
is now the stomach changes to increase
applicants with bachelor's degrees in
physics and astronomy there's a national
test task force that worked well over
here and let's look at some of the
details the co-chair of the of the
report and into will dr. Mary James of
Reed College and professor and dr. Edwin
Virginia than my team the team on task
force members were ten number
Brian pigfoot Tabitha Dobbins sheriff
restrain myself Jedediah is me Maria I'm
Melissa
Richardson Quintin Williams Philip Bo
hammer and our Lima Destin was the team
of project manager the effort of this
report was rather unusual in that it was
based on research that is sociological
researchers helped design a series of
questionnaires that were sent out to
elementary students to ascertain what
was the nature of their experience now
this is of course in the presence of a
background if we look at the number
episodes of
tres degrees earned by F Dominicans Pro
period of 1999 to 2017 what we find is
that for for the number of
african-americans then you see some
fluctuation it fluctuates from about 150
to just under 300 that percentage is
between 5% and unfortunately 4% the
number of bachelor's degrees learned in
physics from 1955 to 2018 looks as the
slide that shows next where we see a
purple region showing that around 1955
they were just over 2500 of bachelor's
degrees and earned by every student in
the United States up until 2018 with
that number this length is 9000 but if
we look at the growth of bachelor's
degrees awarded to african-americans
looking at all colleges what we find is
something very anomalous if we look at
all skin fields we find that there's a
growth from just or I'm sorry percentage
growth that if you start with 1995 is no
reference start with zero percent by
2017 there's over a hundred percent
growth in all skin disciplines some of
these disciplines of course are very
differently to the way they responded
for example if we look at the earth
sciences their percentage growth is over
200 percent in this period on the other
hand if we look at engineering the
growth where is about sixty percent
chemistry has fluctuated over time but
even in chemistry we see over a 50
percent growth rate of all of the skin
feelings what we find is that physics
has the slowest and lowest percentage of
growth rate over this time frame and in
particular we can look at the issue
about is it all minority students and
what we find on the next slide is the
answer is no a reference point is to
look at this fanuc students and this is
a study that was done in 2009 as shown
in figure
slides well fine as for Hispanic
students the growth from 1994 to 2017
those rows are 2 percent to about 8
percent over that same time period
essentially receive no growth than the
percentage of african-american
bachelor's degrees awarded to an
American bachelor's degrees who were
awarded in the area of physics so our
field of physics is very anomalous now
this is a problem that was uncovered by
studying the data and because that found
where physicists we let agenda but what
can we do about it well there are a
number of things that are in this stem
up report and I hope the person who is
showing my slides will share with you
the the WWE IP org website if you just
google the expression stem and a IP and
team up we will be likely able to find
report and it is chock full of
Statistics as well as comments from the
students being interviewed it has a
serious recommendations that people are
looking to implement and one of the
recent things that we've initiated here
United States is a new coalition
it's called Delta Phi for change physics
roughly a week ago we Delta Phi had this
inaugural webinar it was well attended
we had over 2700 registrants at the
beginning of a two-hour session and by
the end of the session there were 1600
pairs of eyes still looking now this
Delta Phi as a coalition is a coalition
built of the American Physical Society
the American Institute of Physics the
National Society of black businesses the
American the african-american women in
physics organization and a new group of
young physicists the beyond the standard
model and Dimmick and then finally the
American Association of physics teachers
this is also a video that you can find
online
in fact you follow the scene
part of it in my presentation today
where things go is playing and this
effort is a coalition we want to make a
difference and in particular given the
situation with you mr. Floyd there's a
lot of attention on asking questions
what are the barriers that African
Americans or more generally people of
color encounter as they enter our field
so that is if you're really motivated to
make a difference I tell young people
join in join these organizations that
are trying to make a difference in our
first webinar we actually showed a
number of leaders and tools that
interested parties can use to try to
make their individual contribution to
making a difference what I'd like to do
next is something rather different from
my presentation doing the webinar the
person who has my transparencies can
either go along as I talk or these
transparencies I believe will be made
available to anyone who's actually
interest in this session so I have some
recollections basically I will be 70
years old in December something all goes
well of course and I since 1995 I've
been presumably small a small number of
written reflections on my journey and
observations as a scientist who is
african-american these works are in the
form of essays not published directed
narratives and each essay is a
free-standing document though there are
conceptual links and overlaps between
them each was written after a period of
some duration focused on answering a
question raised by someone else if left
to my own natural tendencies I would
return to a difference or the question
namely why is the mathematics of
space-time super symmetry that lies at
the foundation and harness string
theories so incompletely
then poorly understood however pushed by
other people interested in talking about
these questions I've thought about these
matters majorities of my writings
address questions around post-secondary
education and the struggle to maintain
the meager and modest progress
that has occurred within my lifetime
please do not deeply engage the question
of whether I want ideas of whether in
STEM disciplines and the concept can be
black nor if such do exist do they
matter these are not the kinds of
questions that I as us trained
physicists know how to answer
neither have I written on the question
of whether racism is systemic or a
fractal tessellation in their
disciplines this is something that
people can study for decades or perhaps
centuries again I'm not qualified to
answer that question however I can tell
you something has changed in my lifetime
the prima facie evidence for this is by
my very existence as the first
african-american theoretical physicist
elected to the US National Academy of
Sciences since it was established by
President Lincoln and this makes project
progress impossible for me to deny I do
not represent myself as an authority in
this complicated domain of human society
as I will only present my thoughts for
others to essay contemplate evaluate and
weigh as they come to decisions about
their own beliefs and actions I
fervently wish I could present data or
mathematics as that is the foundation
with which we scientists are most
familiar and comfortable unfortunately
the numbers of relevant data points is
so small that I can only often offer
anecdotes and thoughts that are derived
from things before I provide the promise
links leading to my thoughts because I
don't have time to actually go over them
there's one of the figure I believe
especially physicist might wish to
consult on the matter of racist
practices committed against African
Americans in the US and of course we see
echoes of these practices and treatments
towards many people around the world
unfortunately too many of us a residue
of this seems to apply in physics and
more generally the STEM disciplines if
there's a secular Pope in the
Magisterium of physics its Albert
Einstein though almost universally
reviewed by physicists very
you are aware of what Albert Einstein
described as a disease he found in the
USA when should you know where that even
Einstein was not a perfectly not a being
of perfect perfection on the topic of
race this was demonstrated by some of
his writings after a visit to age in the
early 1920s however he spoke powerfully
about his impressions of racism directed
towards african-americans in his adopted
country after immigrating here so in the
following I will recommend to my fellow
physicists thoughts from Albert Einstein
via a set of links once again we don't
have the time to dig very deeply into
these if you are interested please go to
these links and read and learn about
what Albert Einstein said about race in
America I hope that content will prove
to be useful to the reader so there's a
series of links I have about writings
from Albert Einstein the first is
actually a book so Einstein didn't write
the booklet the officer Jerry Fred
Jerome knew Roger Taylor the book is
entitled Einstein with race and racism
it was actually published in 2006 and I
believe it is still available to the
public for the slides that I have
accompany my talk there's a link to it
and you can dig into that and see what
Einstein said because it was quite
powerful in this description and his
decrying the practices that he saw in
the United States the secondly that I'm
providing chose something very
interesting about Albert Einstein now
what Einstein made a visit to a prefer
to a all-black College called Lincoln
College in 1946 or 47 it was at a time
when he basically had stopped giving
commencement addresses at universities
but he made an exception on this
particular time and this secondly
actually has some photographs of Iceland
on the Macon University campus meeting
with the president president bond who in
fact is the father of the famous civil
rights worker and Julian Bond in fact
Julian Bond met Einstein on this
occasion and you can read about this at
the second link
I have had the pleasure of meeting
fridge Ron and Roger Taylor who
unfortunately deceased now some years
ago in 2007 the three of us were at
Harbor talking about some of the results
in their book Minds final race and
racism and that link is still active you
can go there it has some comments and
one of the things at that presentation
that I thought about was why Einstein
honey don't get these fellas finally
there's a link number 4 you can see a
copy of the meaning of the newspapers
that heralded and recognized Heinz Heinz
unusual commencement address in 1946 and
this is the links for number 4 and 5
about Einstein my own throat trajectory
has been rather interesting to me as I
think about it from the outside
we started in 1995 I wrote an article
called equity versus excellence a false
dichotomy in science and society this is
available at the link shown under number
one and this was the first time I
started thinking about based on my
experiences what if what is what is the
role of diversity how can we balance
this about equity and excellence because
I always tell people if we lose
excellence we lose the reason that
physics is so very important the second
link that I am indicating with my slides
it's an article I wrote which were about
my thoughts on creativity diversity and
innovation in science and engineering
this was a piece that was actually
solicited from me as all of my writings
in this area and this was for a book a
I'm sorry a publication called diversity
in the law that was created by a
coalition of organizations including the
American Association of universities
among others this particular essay
there's actually taking on a life of its
own you can actually see the essay by
going to
second part of the number two late
and strangely law this very essay has
been cited by the Supreme Court
the third thing they're actually will
show you the essay in the context of the
citation by the Supreme Court I think
this means I'm may be the only living
theoretical physicist whose writings
have been cited by the US Supreme Court
and then finally there's a short essay
that I wrote or on the question of
affirmative action University and
college admissions it was a response to
a very interesting question that was
asked in 207 by Chief Justice Roberts
there was a hearing underway arguments
were going back and forth and the Chief
Justice asked the question what
particular value there's a minority
student brain no physics facts now I was
in Australia when this question was
asked but the reporter reached out to me
and asked me what I thought about I
thought the question was very peculiar
and I do wonder about its origin but
this short essay under the Fourth Way
was my response to Chief Justice Roberts
and once again I an invite anyone who's
interested in still aim to go ahead and
study these links thank you to the
organizers thank you to dr. Kaname thank
you to Jeff Rubin who I have actually
seen in decades
I mean first met him in 2000 on my
second visit to South Africa and I wish
everyone the very best I understand but
the strains 2020 wound has been
fantastic and go and do some great
physics because what else we gonna do